oh hello I didn't hear you come in
welcome to every damn day well since
you're joining me and the years almost
over it's a great time to sit back and
reflect on all the incredible things I
did this year yep that's right it's the
Jordan Mendoza clip show everyone was
asking for you may be thinking Jordan
show me a single comment that asked for
this or Jordan you just let yourself
into the studio while everyone was on
vacation with their families well I
don't have a family you guys are my
family whether you like it or not now
I've done a lot of things on this show
that in other workplaces would have been
frowned upon like that time I fed my
co-workers cupcakes I implied were
poisoned but had actually just air
humped I basically had sex with these
cupcakes so enjoy it oh wow the memories
can't believe I wasn't fired
speaking of fired this one earned me a
talking-to
[Music]
ha good thing we don't have HR right
Nader and good thing Ryan's apartment
doesn't have a security system
hey I heard something go check it out oh
it's Jordan from work I'm on the phone
anyways it's crazy that Marvel has a
movie called Captain Marvel oh wow what
a hilarious Captain Marvel joke want to
hear it again what do you guys look it
looks great it's just it's weird that
Marvel has a movie called Captain Marvel
that's like if Tommy central had a show
called Captain Marvel I think it's weird
that Marvel has comic called Captain
Marvel what would that be right that's
like if Comedy Central had a show called
Captain Marvel it's so weird that Marvel
has a movie called captain it's so weird
that little has DC would be like
Superman Batman those guys which is
weird weird that Marvel has a movie
called Captain Marvel it's weird that
Marvel working it's weird that a Marvel
has a comic book called Captain Marvel
that'd be like a Comedy Central file
next to me next to this voice and Liam
Neeson's voice you wouldn't be able to
tell the difference that'd be like if
Comedy Central had to show like often
crunch but in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
Wow
that was funny Jordan whether I'm
getting drunk on set or high unsaid or
times upping my colleagues can't wait to
see what the New Year's holds for George
a demon dodo remember you're my family
and you don't snitch our family this has
been every damn jorday play me out
Jordan SpongeBob and Squidward having
sex international waters right that was
great real mix one time in this girl
okay we are like 12 years old this girl
by God Jim pecans to a trail mix okay
and I said ooh that's disgusting why
would you do that
and I was the truth no you know
counts I think I did it I'm not in my
journal that we tested HR like there are
four cameras watching this HR is
actually the girl Jordan data on the
third floor
[Music]